dominique aujourd'hui nous allons faire
la brouillade nemours mais je ne savais
pas que tu étais un grand chef cuisinier
du mois non je suis quelqu'un qui aime
faire la cuisine
j'ai appris la cuisine à l'école
hôtelière de nice puis ma mère tu te
provençal qui aimait faire la cuisine
qui faisait très bien la cuisine
alors j'ai appris avec un la fabrique
usine puis je reçois des amis ça me fait
plaisir de faire la cuisine
alors tu va nous donner la recette oui
je sais le papier et le crayon c'est ça
le plus bas alors pour 6 personnes oui
il faut il faut 4 kg de moules mais le
kilo les coquilles des gourmands oui il
y en a qui jouent bien et surtout c'est
bon alors il faut des moules de
méditerranée le d'espagne qui n'a pas
tellement de gauche il punit une moule
de l'oceane et d'un bol de calais qui
est une très belle mme lemay afin qu'ils
ne nierai pas pour cette recette qu'il
faut ou de la bouzigue de la moule de
toulon ils font d'abord avec des moules
bien les laver
on s'est longtemps sinon c'est pas leur
gratter non gratae faux nom le groupe et
non j'ai un truc là je mets dans l'eau
je mets un peu de sel gros mais c'est le
marc hé oui voilà et je les frotte ça
nettoie les toits suffisamment pour les
ouvrir un peu le truc
les grandes mauvais ça veut dire la
taille ça veut dire tu remues aux gens
les zougois
oui oui mais je préfère comme ça et tu
me prépares mais je te dis gentiment ça
qu'est-ce que j'enlève que la la
qu'est-ce que je coupe pour la partie
alors les tomates oui c'est important
ah bon on commençait sa 11e trou non je
te fais voir tu enlèves d'abord le pecq
ou la wii ce que ça en français ça
s'appelle le pédoncule un très bon mois
tu relèves que la coupe par le mieux et
qui arriva sur le soldat pas tout laisse
penser un peu probable
dans le beurre si tu vois que le beurre
mannequin peu oui parce qu ils se
seraient pas l'économie il faut rajouter
voilà qui ne reviennent pas cher les
moules se cacher fait partir j'attends
un manomètre like ou comment les tomates
quant au parti de me fait à peu près du
haut tu me voilà de chaque moitié tu me
fais une carte peu près tous partis de
chaque moitié tu me fais une carte
acceptée des mathématiques
allez vas-y faut pas qu'on l'aura
compris alors tu dois partir ça bien tu
rajoute un peu de beurre tu veux pas
mettre du beurre tu peux mettre 2
millions de livres 6,9 m avec le barça
mais si la meilleure tout va bien tout
va me coincer le retrait avant tout non
l'équivalent de sa peu près 2 celui-là
je suis là parce qu'elle en dit dans
y'en a du pouvoir syrien mais si je suis
là qu'est le meilleur je te dire comme
en fait foi
je suis là c'est ma fabrication
personnelle je vais te dire comment je
le fais je mets une portion de poivre
blanc
une passion de poivre noir inquiétez pas
le rhône une fois vos grilles une pauvre
il n'existe pas et ensuite je prends le
tiers de ce poids total
et j'ajoute du corium c'est les petites
boules comme un agneau du poireau
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt des petites
boules c'est ça qu'on met dans les
années ont passé
alors là c'est ce que tu as mis là
dedans c'est les trois mélanges et que
tu ok alors faire ça commence à faire
partir et on rajoute voulait remonter un
peu le feu sont bien le problème c'est
prison ferme et a alors tu mets ça là
bas tu l'as où froid dire j'étais le
gars bikers ici et là je repars tu vois
ça c'est bien mais lui est bienvenue bon
je rajoute mumbai que jettera j'aime
tout comme ça les coutumes à préparer la
juste comme ça comme un tournant pour
justin tout comme sa voix à peine de la
coupe et n'est rien ok on peut partir
nous sommes en ce moment a ajouté encore
divers toujours au pif salle toujours
plus loin je vais pas la cuisine avec
une membre et l'emballage les balances
sébum pour les pâtissiers mais pas pour
les cuisiniers voilà la cuisine ça se
sent et ça se regarde sa mort mais oui
ça sent bon mais cet automate elle est
un peu anémique que tu vas en étant
d'isère je veux lui donner un polar ou
gens là ma sauce de quoi donner un peu
de couleur c'est juste pour faire joli
non c'est pas pour faire joli et c'est
pour faire joli pendant les goûts aussi
pour la beauté et après vas-y non chez
marin voilà comme ça aussi c'est parti
on va arriver à mettre le feu voilà eh
bien on va les voir bien sûr le moule et
si un peu les décortiquer décortiquer
les moins a alors j'ai trois une
coquille vide ton sac sa technique
commune sa civic qui me trouble sa
dernière va t 4 kg de moules midi quatre
kilos ça fait beaucoup regardent on
ironisé le montagne tout à l'heure un
non pas la petite colline beaucoup je
vais tourner un peu masos ces années
je vais vous retrouver le goût un peu
parce que j'ai pas mis de sel depuis le
début je me mets fait toujours je vais
voter
s'enchaînent alors c'est l'impasse elles
n'ont pas bien je suis pas contre ça
rien à voir
j'ajoute auraient tout à l'heure bon et
bien écoute pendant que je m'occupe des
moules tu me bats les e1 je me laissais
pas une assiette tu mets les blancs d'un
côté les roues dans l'offre tu me bats
les bars ne peut pas en neige même
fameux presse pourquoi
ok les yeux on en met 12 ans bien sûr
d'accord 2 e par personne ne s'est pas
beaucoup ça se passe bien vains privé je
mets mes moules au désert
donc ça y est alors moi ça y est ouais
c'est pas fait pour revenir mais moule
mais faut pas les prêts/emprunts voilà
faut pas que sa grille voilà plus tu vas
chercher tentes cognac ça c'est
important
même si ben voilà battus les bas un peu
comme ça oui encore un peu poils et les
flammes mais tout moment j'arrêtais de
bible et intérêts bassin très bien nous
allons rajouter là dedans notre crème
fraîche ou chanter alors puis les
ménages
c'est là que le travail commence tu mets
une tombe et d'huile d'olive une tombée
alors tu ne vas pas qu on a eu aussi tu
vas mettre tout ça soit bien il est noir
sitôt que ça va partir
on va rajouter le mélange est déjà là
d'accord
parmi sa part gül
oui ça me donne c'est pour ça c'est fini
alors là il ya deux solutions
non toutes les deux sont bonnes ou tu le
dresse sur un plat oui et une nappe avec
la sauce qui est là qui est encore
chaude bien à naples ou alors tu fais
une sauce dr tu as aussi levé d'honneur
une saucière apa chacun se sert et ce
n'est pas chacun à sa volonté
j'aurais dû goûter quand je te faire
goûter dessus voilà je te fais voté par
petits bouts et
[Musique]